[Music]
foreign welcome to the pretty intense
podcast continuing with my fascination
of the theme of the universe and reality
and are there extraterrestrials out
there Jill Tarter is on the show she was
a former director of The seti Institute
which is the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence she inspired the Jody
Foster role in the movie contact one of
my top five movies it kind of led me to
her and just listening to her speak and
her General search for extraterrestrials
and are we alone I mean that is a big
question in my mind so we had a really
interesting conversation we didn't talk
about whether or not it's true because
she's not into giving her an opinion but
we talked about the facts we talked
about what's actually being done the
technology what could be received from
another planet or another star versus
also what we're putting out there we
could receive a message and how we are
continuing to evolve the technologies
that it takes to receive a message and
the timeliness of it Discovery Magazine
said that she is one of the most
important women in science that I feel
like I was just talking to a legend
enjoy the show please hit subscribe and
the like button and let me know are we
alone in the comments are we looking for
the right thing with us I'd love to hear
your thoughts well you search what is
one of the most fascinating things to me
I have looked up to the sky from the
time I was really young and just
like it's the only it's the thing that
gives me a headache because I think it
goes on for Infinity but then what's at
the end of there's nothing it goes it
keeps going there must be an end but
what would that be and is that like what
you used to think when you were a kid
when you looked up to the sky now when I
looked up to the sky as a kid I looked
up and I thought one of those Stars
there's going to be a planet and there's
going to be some little kid on that
planet walking along with their parent
and seeing
seeing our star in their Sky our son as
a star in their sky and they're going to
be wondering whether anybody is up there
looking at them I agree with you I I my
opinion being that there's no way we're
alone like it's there's way too much
it's an awful waste of space are those
actually your words
[Music]
they're the screenwriters was the scene
of you walking with your dad in the
movie part of your part of your
contribution or because when you said
that that's immediately what I thought
is that that was a scene in the movie
yes yeah that's really cool how did that
even come about that's so interesting I
think we just got a phone call I Know
Carl was writing the book I told Carl
about this experience that I'd had just
after I got my PhD I went to a meeting
in Washington I think it was the
American Association of women in science
that's sponsored it anyway I walked into
a room full of 80 women 80 really smart
clever women and it just was a
life-changing event having been the only
woman in 300 of my engineering class
I had just gotten used to walking into
rooms full of men walking into this room
full of women who were all bright and
smart and
talented it was spectacular we
swapped stories of how we managed to
make it through the pipeline when so
many others didn't many of the women
overwhelming number of the women their
dads were the biggest influence in their
life and that was my case right
unfortunately my dad died
when I was young he died when I was 12.
one of the things I learned from that
was this Carpe Diem idea you know don't
put off asking a question of your father
till tomorrow because he might not be
there
and it's amazing how many of the other
women had the similar kind of experience
were there questions that you wish you
would have asked oh sure infinite number
how do I make it through this life
I deal with yeah all the challenges that
will be coming right I didn't know
enough dance you have to ask those then
I mean you know you say that and how do
you make it through this life and you
know there's a lot of esoteric thoughts
that go through my mind and people I
speak to and I don't know if that is the
same for you but so many people will
reply with I don't want to come back
next time next time around I'm not doing
this it's too hard do you believe in
that sort of idea that you come back
again I don't think so I but I don't
have any scientific data to support it
or refute it it just doesn't seem to be
um a mindset that is comfortable for me
is that is that represent is that true
how scientifically based you are with
everything that you believe in is that
it really does need to come down to
science is that is that the real you
yeah that's what I'm comfortable with
yes I mean truly my my favorite part in
the movie as
the scene of asking to prove love for
your dad and I really like that was just
such a I never forgot that scene
um so how would you explain love then I
mean I'm just might as well ask you you
know if you can't prove love how do you
know but it still exists right it exists
and I don't know why you have to prove
it
um it's an emotion that sometimes you're
lucky enough to be able to experience
and share and therefore
it's an emotion it isn't science
um
so I don't know why you don't just
appreciate it and live with it does that
not apply then when it comes to the
question of are we alone and that can
you just believe it without proof no the
are wheel question requires uh an
extraordinary amount of evidence to be
able to a infer that that's what you've
that you've found evidence for someone
else's technology that's what we're
trying to do
and be then interpret that evidence and
using a lot of other expertise that I
don't particularly have but I think if
that problem were posed there would be
no lack of individuals and organizations
who would try to figure out what it was
that we were actually finding 2016 I
think it was where there were multiple
claims of detection of extraterrestrial
intelligence there were much better
explanations for each of the claims in
the end
and I've been since then sort of on a
hobby horse
reminding people that back in the 80s at
the International Academy of
astronautics and The International
Institute of Space law we developed a
set of principles
um
regarding actions following the
detection of extraterrestrial
intelligence and really keep trying to
remind people
of those principles and how how to do a
search and how to get confirmation of
what you've found and how to tell the
world and I think if I recall back in
the 80s the the motivation for
constructing this set of principles was
the fact that our Soviet colleagues
in the former Soviet Union we're doing
study searches we were concerned that if
they should be successful they would be
prevented from sharing that information
so we developed this set of principles
and one of the things that says number
eight is you know make sure that you
know what you've got and then tell the
world when you think about this
and you think about the technology that
we have now
which we didn't have in the 1980s there
are better ways of searching ways of
searching that lend themselves to
confirmation and verification and
validation oh really
um like using two telescopes and finding
the same thing in both telescopes with
three time delays between them
so
that's
that's sort of where I'm spending my
time and effort now that and trying to
build an endowment
because we now
deeply understand that this may be a
multi-generational
search effort and so it might be my
great granddaughter that succeeds
eventually in finding evidence of
someone else's technology right we have
to find a way to keep not huge amounts
of funding but at least Dependable
funding year upon year generation after
generation and of course universities
figured out how to do that Millennia
though right development endowments
that's a big undertaking it is but it's
worth it I mean yeah you always want the
best and the brightest right people to
be joining you and you always have to
recruit your Replacements and so the
recruiting job is is somewhat difficult
because you can't promise success and
most young scientists and Engineers want
to say well in my career I'm going to do
X Y and Z and I'm going to be well
rewarded and famous for that and of
course I can't say that in fact I have
to say hmm well yeah you can make it
famous but I'm not sure I can make
payroll at the end of the month
and they're like how much of a passion
project is this if you do you really
believe that there is life out there it
actually doesn't matter what I believe
right this is science and so it matters
what I can prove if I told you I knew
the answer that would be religion and
not science so what I believe doesn't
matter what I can find through
scientific exploration
does matter what do you want to find
well it's a big question and I'd like to
know
what other ways there are to make a
biology and to make a technology or is
us and what happened here the only way
it can manifest
seems unlikely
don't know the answer to that right we
can we can look and now I mean our tools
are getting better all the time we're
building bigger telescopes we're
building all kinds of spacecraft for
exploration
um I know we've got the Rovers on Mars
that are caching
Rock samples to be picked up later and
to be showing that really earlier on
Mars was wet and warm and salty Wow
might have been a place where life could
get started I interviewed Brian Cox he
thought that by taking core samples from
Mars that maybe it would leave it would
give us some kind of understanding as to
how we came about
and my question was it might have just
come about just the way that we're going
to Mars and taking a core sample that
like life came from somewhere else and
went oh let's just see what's going on
over here and that it seems like the
most likely most likely scenario that it
happened just the same
well that's that that idea is often
called panspermia that life came from
somewhere else and seated uh life here
and what would not necessarily disprove
but at least make less likely that story
would be if we found a biology that was
totally independent from Life as we know
it I mean all life that we currently
know is related right and based on the
same kind of biology and
um molecular coding if we found a
totally independent
um biology then that would make it less
likely that were clones of or seeds from
someplace else I I as I said I'm very
fascinated with this realm
um so uh I also spoke to Neil deGrasse
Tyson and uh quite a while ago and I
asked him are we looking for the wrong
thing like if we're looking for ourself
and he said what you said that we are
made of the most common most common
elements in the universe so it's it just
seems natural to look for something of
ourself but uh
I don't know how comfortable you are
with opinions but in your opinion do you
think that that's do you agree with that
and do you think that there is a chance
that looking for
um biology that is just like us or a
human-esque like entity is actually
um all there could be out there or is
there other other I mean with even
within our Visual and audio Spectrum
like we hear and see such a small sliver
of it so what about the potential that
by looking for us we're not looking for
everything well we're certainly not
looking for everything right when we
look
um and but the the other side of that
coin is we're looking for what we can
we're looking for what our technology
allows us to look for we don't know how
to look for Zeta Rays or some other
physics or biology that we haven't yet
uncovered so there is a limitation and
this is the 21st century and we're using
the tools that we have at our disposal
someday we'll be able to do other things
but right now we're doing what we can
and the thing that um I think will help
answer this question about is there only
one way to make life is
synthetic biology that is now taking
place in the lab I used to say we're
never going to answer this question
about what is
um necessary and what is contingent for
life
until we found a second independent
example
but now in the lab I think we are
exploring these questions and we may be
able to come up with
an irreducible set of requirements for
for life and that it just can't be any
other way you've got to start with that
and then you can elaborate on it in many
different ways
but I'm so I'm I'm eager to see what
comes out of those studies so would that
be the progression that you're referring
to about transitioning more to Ai and
robots and other forms of essentially
intelligence
that could populate other places in the
universe that it starts with humans or
something like a human and has sort of
an intelligent progression well
something has to invent a robot right
the robot didn't put itself together
right so at some time maybe no longer
but at some time there was something
that could build a robot and then the
robots got really
smarter than the the maker and they
progressed faster because their
evolutionary time scale is and not the
biological evolution that we have to
deal with but they can reinvent
themselves and build the Next Generation
much faster and and with more capability
than biology can so how do you feel
about that do you are you comfortable
like does that I think this scares a lot
of people you know it scares me to a
degree like transitioning out of human
body and then I think about
Consciousness and what is that and and
how does that overlay it scares me a
little yeah well what I'm comfortable
about is that people are asking these
questions right I think we're beginning
to think about it and we're beginning to
think about how do you constrain machine
intelligence how do you uh
make sure that it has the right set of
principles and doesn't deviate from them
and and I don't have answers to those
questions all I can say is that people
are beginning to ask the questions which
does make me comfortable because going
just going out you know looking for this
um extraordinarily brilliant Singleton
um
without thinking about constraining
is not the right way to push ahead
so I'm glad yeah I'm comfortable with
the fact that people are beginning to
talk about it looking for answers now I
don't have any answers yet what do you
think the best and worst case scenario
is as far as I understand it artificial
intelligence making a decision that
decision is based on statistics if you
give
an advanced intelligence a goal which is
to manufacture a million paper clips
right it's going to ask itself all right
have I already made a million paper
clips and then because the answer is
statistical it can never be certain
whether it has or not and you could
imagine the runaway scenario which is oh
well
and I'm not quite sure let me just make
some more until it used all the
resources available
in the local region to make more paper
clips
um it's the fact that a decision is
going to be a statistical
thing and a machine could get on the
wrong side of that and decide that it
just doesn't have yet enough data has to
go do some more
and you never you could never possibly
get out of that infinite Circle
so I think that would be a bad outcome
and you know there are people like that
people who have
ideas
which are demonstrably wrong
by a number of
um external criteria
but they refuse to accept those criteria
and continue to pursue their wrong ideas
sure sure I mean it could happen with it
happens as patterns as people we we keep
repeating the same Loop that we learned
through childhood I mean patterns are
kind of fundamental for us yeah that's
actually one of the things that make me
interested in artificial intelligence is
since we began this search for
someone else's technology study we've
been taking
um the output the voltages from various
sensors telescopes and spacecraft and
we've been saying all right
is this pattern in the data and we've
predefined the pattern as being
something that according to us
um nature can't do but technology can
what I'm hoping is that artificial
intelligence will allow us to take away
um that prescription of a pattern and
simply be able to ask
is there any information in these data
not is this pattern present okay like
actually figuring out if it's consistent
with anything that exists in our world
um yeah
I think that's getting pretty close to
it but just not having to
pre-define what we're looking for
because we might you know we might be
doing an extraordinarily Exquisite job
of looking for the wrong thing right
we should be looking I think I mentioned
it or we should be looking for Zeta rays
but we don't know what a Zeta Ray is yet
yeah sometime in the future if we ever
invent them then we're going to try and
figure out how we can use them
in this search for someone else's
technology what are some new questions
that have come about example like oh
what are what is a state array right if
there's just something new that emerges
what are some of the new questions based
on what you found that have emerged in
the last 10 or 20 years oh look two
things one searching the data collection
and the analysis of the data in near
real time so that we have some
sensitivity to things that are transient
if you operate where you gather data
and put it in storage and you analyze it
two months later right you're not going
to be able to re-look re-observe
validate and confirm a transient signal
that lasted for a minute are you
thinking you could follow it then or is
there some sort of if you can look back
quickly enough that is on a time scale
that is short compared to the time scale
on which the phenomenon changes then you
do have a way you know you do have the
possibility of following up and
validating it so that looking for
transients is um
is something that's new that we're
trying to be able to do
and then again looking for patterns that
aren't predefined looking for
information in the data as
with whatever current metrics
the
um artificial intelligence folks
have for saying that's information rich
or that has no information that's
astrophysical
have there been has there been data
that's been collected that when you look
back in example two months later or
something like that that has been
interesting or compelling but leads to
nothing because of its potential of
being transient or they're not being
necessarily like a next step to see like
what is the next
what is the next thing to look at
um is there are there dead ends that you
guys have found that you've found in
collection of data because of the
timeline what we've seen
is Publications and claims
that
um signals have been found
um
and and it's you know it was a whole
series of papers not just one a couple
of authors from Canada published us a
long series of papers and said
that there were patterns there were
pulses
coming from all kinds of different Stars
were
the same in some sense
and it took it took a long time and some
very clever people at Berkeley actually
who finally showed that when you take
time series data
and you Fourier transform it that's a
mathematical process and then you
Fourier transform it again you would
basically can introduce or discover a
pattern of pulses that is the result of
the fact that
and natural physical absorption lines in
your Spectra
due to
elements and molecules
in the in the environment and the fact
that the spacing between the absorption
features that they pose onto the data
it's not random there's a mathematical
pattern between seeing one feature an
absorption spectrum and then seeing the
second harmonic of it Etc
it took a very long time as I said to
prove that these claims that
um
pulses were being found were in fact
just the mathematical manipulation of
the natural Spectra and the relationship
between the spacing of absorption
features
so these you said natural phenomena so
are these
ramble for a second here
um so is this energy from a star energy
from a planet energy from a certain
place in outer space that is a harmonic
of that that star or that planet or is
it actually a message a purposeful
message yeah that was that was that was
the claim right
um that since they were looking at lots
of different stars and actually even
lots of different galaxies and then
we're finding this same pulse structure
that it had to be a purposeful message
um turns out that nature is nature is
pretty clever and our mathematical
manipulations really just
um
introduced a pattern so you have to you
have to be careful about that
um
it makes me think a little bit about how
observing something changes the wave
structure
and so our is is the fact that we are
observing it changing
some kind of frequency structure that
you're receiving it could it could and
this is again a a fundamental quantum
mechanical uh
principle about
observation changing the uh the reality
um
but these were data that were collected
by an optical telescope right right and
then this
the time series was turned into a
frequency Spectra and then understanding
what that manipulation was doing
um and it especially a second Fourier
transform uh so
yeah I mean
quantum mechanics tells us that when you
observe something
you know you the wave function is going
to collapse and you will change it's
structured so that makes it really
tricky
well I'm glad there are smart people
that are working on this are we sending
a message are we sending a purposeful
message is there a machine that is
creating a frequency and sending that
out into the universe right now from our
planet yeah we've done a couple of
stunts think about it if you transmit
whatever your message is however you
want to to create it and transmit it if
you transmit it for five minutes
that message is going to go past your
intended target in five minutes right
it's only going to be visible for five
minutes and so at the Target somebody
would have to be looking
at you with exactly the right tools at
exactly the right time so transmission
for me has always been a long-term
project
and I don't think we're grown up enough
to take that on right I think that um
if you start to transmit you have to
continue
and and do it for time scales that we
humans are not used to dealing with you
know tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of years
so you asked if we're transmitting as I
said there were these stunts limited
time but we are also
um
leaking radiation right we have
broadcast transmitters that are leaking
off the planet and of course they're not
very strong because they're intended to
illuminate the next County not the next
star system but with some sufficiently
advanced technology it might be
detectable we are modifying our
atmosphere because of biology and
Technology
so the components in our atmosphere are
well first of all it's highly oxygenated
due to life
um due to photosynthesis
and the um
some of the trace gases are remnants of
Technology
um
that's our technology yeah our
technology that could be seen at a
distance
um
so we are
detectable by a sufficiently advanced
um
civilization
and detect but you know only
what how long have we well we've been
modifying the atmosphere for 2.4 billion
years but we've been making
technological modifications only for you
know a few decades so that means that
there's a horizon
a few
decade light years that this information
would have propagated is it impressive
to you how far we've come in a short
amount of time as humans I think it's
impressive I think when you think of
well my mother died when she was 98.
um when I think of
the changes that she saw in her lifetime
it's pretty astonishing and
people young people now are all about
change and nothing stays the same
and they are used to the fact and they
begin to expect and require and
anticipate that things will change in
particular their devices will get faster
or more capable or yeah they will have
other ways of communicating with their
um with their peers
and they will be able to access
information in ways that we never could
before
and
so their lives will be different as a
result is there anybody uh is there
someone young it makes me think of just
asking the question if there's somebody
very young with a perhaps completely New
Perspective that's introduced an idea
um
into the realm of
um
the universe and what's out there that
has been Monumental in taking steps
forward and discovering more
well I think the answer to that
inevitably is yes if you limit it to
what we've been doing
yeah there are
um
there's receiver technology
that's new so how you build whatever it
is that takes
the energy that's collected by a
reflector a telescope of some kind
and transforms it into
a voltage as a function of time and then
transforms that into a frequency pattern
those technologies have changed
um their things
just just different kinds of things that
we we didn't have before yeah you can do
and and again often young people
who are clever and come at this from a
different direction and they say oh I
have this
Gadget hmm
and and maybe if I take a look at your
data
that Gadget can tell me something that
you haven't been looking for
so yes and I I hopefully more of that
will happen
um you had mentioned time and
um I was fascinated by the idea of this
time space reality time and space and
what is it and does it exist in in the
universe and and is time and space the
way that we know it is that is that
local is that a is that a local
phenomenon here on the planet well there
have been some experiments again in the
quantum physicists love to talk about
this stuff and and try and do
experiments to the best of my knowledge
they have not found any locality
that that time and space and the physics
that connect them
do seem to be Universal
and not limited to our
our local neighborhood
how does that explain
quantum entanglement then
well that's certainly a non-local
phenomenon I mean it starts out locally
but then you can separate the the
entangled
particles or states by large distances
and yet they instantaneously respond to
a perturbation in one in one place at a
great distance so that's definitely not
local
how does it explain it I don't know I
mean I I think quantum entanglement is
something that lots of smart people are
scratching their heads over spooky
things happening at a distance right is
that what Einstein called it yep he did
and he didn't believe it
but he acknowledged it yeah well but he
he fundamentally did not think that this
um was
up
a part of the structure of the Universe
I find it fascinating that there's
Newtonian physics and then there's
quantum physics or quantum mechanics and
they don't Jive yet they're both
essentially
been proven to be true yeah it's scale
right
so at
at the earliest times and smallest
scales
we cannot yet make gravity
and quantum mechanics play nice together
right so you can't as you try and go
back and describe the structure of the
universe at
smaller scales and earlier times
we see a breakdown we we can't carry it
all the way back to the singularity
and that's just because there's more for
us to learn about the physics of the
universe
do you believe that there is a theory of
everything
yes I do I I do believe that there is
some fundamental
underlying structure
and reason and physics
that will ultimately explain everything
but I think at the moment we're more
like
um when early astronomers were trying to
explain the
um
the orbits of the planets
by using perfect circles right they
weren't allowing for ellipses
and they kept adding complexities so
they added another layer of circles
epicycles and that kind of thing I think
we might be
somewhat in that state in the sense that
we haven't figured out what the ellipse
is that
um helps us
to to get to a theory of everything what
will be the ripple effect of that if you
can if there could be a way to quantify
from scale the largest to the smallest
things
what happens next well it would really
have a big effect on the stock market
I'll say
in what way if we get to be
a multi body or multi-planetary
civilization how are we going to deal
with
making a transaction in one place
when there are all these different time
delays from those who want to make the
transactions being at different
distances away
um
at one point
oh I can't remember who it was someone
uh suggested that uh
neutrinos might help solve this
problem
if we could in fact build neutrino
detectors because they would be able to
take the shortest paths and go right
through everything to get oh it's a
neutrino a neutrino is a fundamental
particle
massless and
it's produced in
high energy collisions
of of particles
and it um
it was very hard to prove the existence
of an neutrino but basically it doesn't
interact with anything so it goes
through land without ever seeing the
lead atoms right
um
and so that wow perhaps neutrinos
could
help solve this transactional difficulty
because they could go straight through
everything and how you trap them that
that of course is the question
um and they wouldn't have to follow the
space-time paths that that photons
take
um how would they travel how would they
travel to another galaxy are you saying
is that what you're implying that it
would be a completely they do they they
do they you're saying they do it's a
trap of neutrino yeah we have these um
very very large underground uh tanks of
essentially cleaning fluid
and what they're waiting for is a
neutrino to have an interaction with one
of the molecules of the cleaning fluid
and produce a little tiny
bit of light that are then captured by
these huge photodiodes that line the
walls of these tanks
um
comeyakani Conde is one there's another
one in Minnesota in a deep mine shaft
anyway
we do have the ability
to detect neutrinos
and we can understand how
infrequently they interact with anything
and so we can understand how far they
can travel without being deflected or
captured
how is it that we're able to understand
how far neutrino came from and where it
came from or perhaps where it's going
to get to a detector on Earth you know
to one of those deep minds or the big
Vats of cleaning fluid neutrino has to
um come through the Earth's atmosphere
and although it's very infrequent
it can interact with a molecule in the
Earth's atmosphere and that molecule or
atom will scatter many others and you
get this air shower
you essentially can
um
map back
where that out in what direction that
air shower came from wow
um but you know it takes
these detectors
are
spread over
hundreds of Acres of real estate oh
really that's true to capture all of the
particles from the air shower and then
um Trace them back
in terms of how far it's come
that's a harder question
um
normally people are guessing
because they will locate an area on the
sky they will go then investigate that
area and see if there are any energetic
um phenomena going on supernova
explosions or anything in that area
and that's not as well defined
we can tell you what direction they came
from
but telling you how far they came is
harder
what about the large seemingly large
obvious artifacts
here on Earth
that exists that seeming that don't have
an explanation like
the pyramids pyramids all over the world
um certain there are
um
materials found here and there that are
not native to this planet
um well that I would that I would
question I think all of them have been
shown to be manufacturable with the
physics that we know in in our local
neighborhood or have been introduced
from an energetic phenomenon that has
been landed on Earth the structures that
we have on Earth I think we do a great
disservice to our distant ancestors by
saying oh they couldn't have possibly
been smart enough to figure out how to
build this right and I particularly
um like
because she's old and she's a woman
that's um
archaeologist who works on the
structures
um in the plains of Nazca and she's
shown how what in terms of Technology
very primitive
civilizations with a lot of time
can manage to do
with
with humans and ropes and
um really
crude
apparatus to recreate those structures
so I think we're just it's just our ego
that's getting in the way there we're
just saying oh
we're smart and Those Distant ancestors
couldn't have possibly been smart enough
to do this have you ever been to have
you been to
um certain ancient civilizations before
no I haven't I've just you know I'm an
armchair scientist in that respect
looking at video and listening to
lectures there's just so much
fascinating stuff out there seeing some
some things in person you just can't you
don't understand it
um I went to Egypt um beginning of last
year and somewhere I've always been
fascinated with and I left and I left
saying we don't get it we just don't get
it like
um and it seems like while we're we are
looking out in the universe for
information there seems like there's
also information here on this planet
do you agree with that or do you think
no I I do agree with that but I the
thing that I think is that the thing
that we don't get is what it's like to
be a human with a different sense of
time
right for us we have to you know it has
to happen tomorrow or maybe tomorrow's
too late
but if you're living with um
a very long view of the future
and a Long View of History then I think
you can imagine doing things that seem
impossible to us
um one of the recent uh recent uh photos
that has come through is the photo of
the black hole
um and a much more Vivid view of it and
how really similar it was to how long
ago I'm trying to think there was like
three I remember seeing like sort of an
original
um sort of projection of what it could
be and it is so similar so what is what
what is that what is the significance of
being able to see a black hole with that
level of clarity mean
well it tests our understanding of
physics it tests what we've gotten right
what we have understood right and to the
extent that we're getting it right then
you'll get any you know that was that
was an incredibly difficult experiment
to do
and took a great deal of data processing
you know years before we got that out
and so we know some things that's that's
the answer to that what did we get right
what did we get wrong well we won't know
what we got wrong
until we begin to um analyze the
discrepancies and and and the
discrepancies have to be on a scale that
we can understand them there may be
discrepancies in our current
picture of a black hole
that are just too fine we haven't yet
found
where our Theory uh doesn't give us a
consistent result
so but basically the fact that we could
do it
says that yeah we got some stuff right
about
gravity and um
and quantum mechanics and
electromagnetic radiation
which is good because as you said
earlier gravity doesn't sort of the
theories don't Jive between Newtonian
physics and quantum physics so what is
gravity
fundamental Force right that any two
objects exert on each other there's an
attraction what about this idea of
Consciousness Consciousness is something
that
um again this is something Neil said
he's like when there's a lot of books
being written on something we don't
understand he's like there's not a lot
of physics books out there because it's
just what it is but when there's a lot
of books being written we don't
understand so what is it what is what is
consciousness and why are so many people
writing books about it why are so many
people curious about it what is it about
Consciousness that is so fascinating to
us right now we're fascinated with
ourselves
no I mean it's the thing that we like to
study the most and Consciousness is
something that we believe that is a part
of us
and you know we don't have a good
explanation for it certainly I don't
that's not my area of expertise at all
but do you think it will play into your
search
it could in the sense that what we're
looking for is engineered signals right
and if there's nobody out there with the
kind of cognitive
um
apparatus
that decides that it's useful
to send deliberate engineered signals or
that decides to modify its environment
for their own reasons in ways that we
could detect then whether Consciousness
plays
a role in making those decisions
is in fact important and you know there
may be nothing for us to find because
some other
entity
has made a conscious decision not to
create it I don't know I mean this is
just far out of my Neil likes to
speculate but I'm not comfortable you
said you're retired though how much how
much work do you do now I do
um a lot of I review a lot of papers and
I work on trying to raise an endowment
I work with young people
um listening to their ideas when you say
you listen to Young people and their
ideas what does that mean there's a
group at the city Institute and and at
Berkeley
um who have
taking a look at what's around in terms
of instrumentation and they've pointed
to this telescope called the very large
array in Socorro New Mexico you know
it's 27 25 meter radio telescopes and
it's the most productive radio facility
that we have on the planet
and they've said okay
that telescope's looking at the sky all
the time all the time and at some
frequency so how can we take the data
from that tell us those 27 telescopes
and analyze it for study so they figured
out a way and they're working on it now
but within a year or two we should be
able to make a copy of the data coming
out of each of those telescopes and let
the astronomers go ahead and do their
normal Imaging processing but we can
take the copy and we can analyze that
for seti so this is you know people who
understand
um fpgas and the other technologies that
are now available and can figure out how
to do something new
with an existing instrument
in order to get data
all the time and it's called commensal
observing sort of commensals a
biological term that means eating out of
the same dish
and so we're we're trying to do all
kinds of things and then figuring out
we're building new telescopes
depending on the um the decadal process
in the Congress we may build the Next
Generation vla and spread it all over
the southwest of the U.S and we're
building a square kilometer array in the
low frequency piece in Australia and the
higher frequency dishes in South Africa
so how can we take data from those new
instruments and use it for seti
so we used to say that
in order to do new study we had to build
our own telescopes and our own
instrumentation because we were looking
for things that the astronomers were
definitely not looking for and they were
not going to build the telescopes it's
not true anymore they're now building
really interesting instruments and we
have figured out it's possible to
observe commensally on those instruments
we're not going to be looking for the
things the astronomers built the
telescopes to do but we can in fact use
them to do what we want to do so that's
new stuff and that's exciting yeah that
sounds like a lot more information a lot
more data I've heard you use the example
that we've if you took all the water on
the planet we've looked at maybe like a
bathtub's worth of the of the universe
and so it's it's not very much well what
I hear is a lot of a lot of energy and a
lot of fascination with with what's out
there and I I sure am a lot of people
are a lot of people are very fascinated
with what is out there and are we alone
a lot of people have that question
um is this some kind of cosmic Evolution
we don't know the answer to that
question we may be unique we may be
something that was so improbable
that it happened here only once and
nowhere else in which case
I wouldn't call it Cosmic I would call
it a local
don't want to say a miracle because I
don't believe that those Miracles well
thank you very much I appreciate your
time and thank you for all of your
efforts and I hope that this program
goes on for a couple hundred thousand
years and so we figured I hope it
doesn't have to I hope it succeeds
tomorrow and then we won't have to worry
about funding right everybody will be
wanting to do it
amen all right well thank you very much
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button